let's say we have an ellipse the formula
x squared
over a squared plus y squared over b
squared is equal to one and for the sake
of our discussion we'll assume that a is
greater than b and well that does for us
is it lets us know this is going to be
kind of a short and fat ellipse or that
the semi major axis is going to or the
the major axis is going to be along the
horizontal and the minor axis along the
vertical and let's draw that
let me draw this ellipse
i want to draw a thicker ellipse
let's say that's my ellipse and let me
draw my axes
okay this is my the horizontal
right there
and there we have the vertical
and we've you know we've we've studied
ellipse in pretty good detail so far we
know how to figure out it's
the the semi minor uh the semi-minor
radius which in this case we know is b
and that's the same b right there and
that's only the semi-minor radius
because b is smaller than a if b was
greater would be the major radius and
then of course the major radius is a and
that distance is
this right here
now another super interesting and
perhaps the most interesting property of
an ellipse
is that if you take any point on ellipse
on an ellipse
measure the distance from that point to
two special points which we for the sake
of this discussion and not just for the
sake of discussion for pretty much
forever we will call the focuses or the
foci of this ellipse and these two
points they always sit along the major
axis so in this case it's the horizontal
axis and they're symmetric around the
center of the ellipse so let's just call
that those these points and let me call
this one
f1 and this is f2 and it's for focus
focuses
f2 so the super interesting fascinating
property of an ellipse and it's often
used as the definition of ellipse is if
you take any point on this ellipse
and measure its distance to each of
these two points so let's say that i
have this distance right here
let's call this distance
let's call this distance d1
and then i have
this distance over here so i'm taking
any point on that ellipse or this
particular point and i'm measuring the
distance to each each of these two foci
and this is d2
maybe doing a different color
i'm reusing all the colors so this is d2
this whole line right here
that's d2
so when you take when you find these two
distances you sum them up so this d2
plus d1
this is going to be a constant that it
actually turns out is equal to 2a
but it turns out that it's true anywhere
you go on the ellipse let me let me make
that point clear and i'm actually going
to prove to you that this constant
distance is actually 2a where this a is
the same as that a right there so just
to make sure you understand what i'm
saying so let me take another arbitrary
point on this ellipse let's take it
right there and if i were to take
measure the distance from this point to
this focus
let's call that
let's call that point
d3
and then measure it from measure the
distance from this point to that focus
let's call that
d4
d4 if i were to sum up these two points
it's still going to be equal to 2a let
me write that down d3
plus d4 is still going to be equal to 2a
that's just neat and actually this is
often used as the definition for an
ellipse where they say that the ellipse
is a set of all points or sometimes
they'll use the word locus which is kind
of the the graphical representation of
the set of all points that where the sum
of the distances from
from to each of these focuses is equal
to a constant and we'll we'll play with
that a little bit we'll figure out how
do you figure out the focuses of an
ellipse but the first thing to do is
just to to feel satisfied that the
distance if if this is true that it is
equal to 2a and the easiest way to
figure that out is to pick kind of these
these i guess you could call them the
extreme points along the x-axis here and
here right we're already making the
claim that the distance from here to
here
let me draw that in another color
that this distance
plus
this distance over here
is going to be equal to some constant
number and using this extreme point i'm
going to show you that that constant
number is equal to 2a
so let's figure out how to do that so
one thing to realize that these two
focus points are symmetric around the
origin
so whatever distance
this is right here
is going to be the same as this distance
right there right because these two
points are symmetric around the origin
so this
right here is the same distance as that
right
and of course
we have what we want to do is figure out
the sum of this distance and this
longer distance right there
well what's the sum of this plus this
green distance
well this right here is the same as that
so this plus green let me write that
down
so let me write down these let me call
this
distance
i don't know let me call it
let me call it g just to have say let's
call that g and let's call this h
if this is g this is h we also know that
this is g because everything's symmetric
so what's g plus h
well that's the same thing as g plus h
which is the entire
major diameter of this ellipse which is
what well we know the minor radius is a
so this length right here is also a
so the distance
or the sum of the distance from
this point on the lips to this focus
plus this point of ellipse to that focus
is equal to g
plus
h or this big green part which is the
same thing as the major diameter of this
ellipse which is the same thing as 2a
fair enough hopefully hopefully that
that is good enough uh for you
now the next thing to now that we've
realized that is how do we figure out
where these foci stand or if we have
this equation how can we figure out what
these two points are
let's let's figure that out so the first
thing we realize all of a sudden is that
no matter where we go it was easy to do
with these points but even if we take
these this point right here and we say
okay what's this distance and then sum
it to that distance that should also be
equal to 2a and we could use that
information to actually figure out where
the foci lie
so let's say i have let me draw another
let me draw another one
okay no am i using the right okay so
this is
nope don't want to draw a circle
so that's my ellipse
and then
i want to draw the axes for clarity
and let me write down the equation again
just so we don't lose that x squared
over a squared plus
y squared over b squared is equal to 1.
let's take this point right here
these extreme points are always
useful when you're trying to prove
something or they can be i don't want to
say always
now we said that we have these two foci
that are symmetric around the center of
the ellipse
right this is f1 this is f2 and we've
already said that an ellipse is the
locus of all points or the set of all
points that if you take it each of these
points distance from
each of the focuses and add them up you
get a constant number we figure out that
constant number is 2a so we figured out
if if you take this distance right here
and add it to this distance right here
it'll be equal to 2a
right so we could say that
you know if we call
this
d
d1 this is d2 we know that d1 plus d2 is
equal to
2a
an interesting thing here is that this
is all symmetric right
this length is going to be the same d1
is going to be the same as d2 because
everything we're doing is symmetric
these two focal lengths are symmetric
this distance is the same distance as
this distance right there so d1 and d2
have to be the same there's no way that
you could this is the exact center point
of the ellipse this ellipse is symmetric
around around the y-axis so if d1 is
equal to d2 and that equals 2a then we
know that
this has to be equal to a and this has
to be equal to a
fair enough i think we're making
progress
the other thing to think about and we
we've already did that in the previous
drawing of the ellipse is what is this
distance
this distance is the semi-minor radius
which we already learned is b
and this of course is the focal length
that we're trying to figure out
this should already pop into your brain
as a pythagorean theorem problem
so we have
what is it we have the focal length and
we can do it on this triangle or this
triangle i'll do it on this right one
here this focal length is f let's call
that f
f squared
plus b squared is going to be equal to
the hypotenuse squared which in this
case is d2 or a which is equal to a
squared
and now we have a nice equation in terms
of b and a we know what b and a are from
our from our the equation we were given
for this ellipse so let's solve for the
focal length the focal length f squared
is equal to a squared minus b squared
so f the focal length is going to be
equal to the square root of a squared
minus b squared pretty neat and clean
and pretty intuitive way to think about
something so you just literally take the
difference of these two numbers
whichever is larger you you or whichever
smaller you subtract from the other one
you take the square root and that's the
focal distance let's see if we can use
that to apply it to some to some real
problems where where they might ask you
hey find find the focal length or find
the coordinates of the focuses
so let's say i had the equation
x minus one
squared over nine
plus
y
plus two squared
over
four
is equal to one
so let's let's just graph this first of
all this could be interesting so i'll
draw the axes
that's the x-axis this is the y-axis
and we immediately see what's the center
of this the center is going to be at the
point 1 negative 2 and if that's
confusing you might want to review some
of the previous videos center is at one
x is equal to one
y is equal to minus two
that's the center
and then this the major axis is the
x-axis because this is larger and so b
squared is or a squared is equal to nine
or the semi-minor radius is going to be
equal to three so if we go one
two three
don't do three
go there then you have one
two three
no one two three
one two three i think this let's see one
two
three you go there
roughly and then in the y direction the
semi-minor radius is going to be 2 right
the square root of that so b is equal to
2 so you go up 2
then you go down 2. and this ellipse is
going to look something like
let me pick a good color it's going to
look
something like
this
fair enough and what we do want to do is
we want to find out the coordinates of
the focal points so the focal points are
going to sit along the semi-major axis
right and we need to figure out these
focal distances and then we can
essentially just add and subtract them
from the center and then we'll have the
coordinates what we just showed to you
or hopefully i showed to you that the
the focal length or this distance f
the focal length is just equal to the
square root of the dis of the difference
between these two numbers right so it's
the square root of nine minus four
so the focal length is equal to the
square root of
five
so if this point right here is the point
we already showed that this is the point
the center of the ellipse is the point
one comma minus two
this the coordinate of this focus right
there is going to be
one plus the square root of 5
comma minus 2 and the coordinate of this
focus right there is going to be 1 minus
the square root of 5
comma minus 2. and all i did is i took
the focal length and i subtract since
we're along the major axis or the x-axis
i just add and subtract this from the
x-coordinate to get these two
coordinates right there so anyway this
is kind of the the really neat thing
about conic sections that it has these
interesting properties in relation to
these foci or in relation to these focus
points
and in future videos i'll show you the
foci of a hyperbola or the the foci of a
well it only has one focus of a of a
parabola but this is really starting to
get into what makes conic sections neat
everything we've done up to this point
has been much more about the mechanics
of graphing and plotting and figuring
out the centers of conic sections but
now we're getting into a little bit of
the uh the the mathematical interesting
parts of conic sections anyway see in
the next video